eighty-three 2015 we are having one hell
of a show
welcome to the games for stage I am
joined by Marcus Nielsen executive
producer on need for speed at ghost
games so you showed off need for speed I
think a press conference yesterday how
is the reaction bin
you know overwhelmingly positive I must
say you know we always knew that we are
pushing boundaries right you know we
need for speed is about high production
values but this time around I think that
we're just doing something to knocking
out the word to be honest you know
frostbite the first mile engine together
with it you know very creative our team
we have you know makes the game really
you know stand out and you know we have
this really you know cool cooking or
blending we show this this cutscene of
of what the nitrous can be made up by by
people and then blending it through game
graphics and it's seamless and it's you
can't tell the difference so what you're
reaching that point now with where the
game and rail looks really the same it's
an interesting way to kind of bypass the
uncanny valley it take place it was so
smooth and I'm certainly when I was
watching it I did yeah here it is
you couldn't tell where the game started
where the video ended no and that was
obviously the real trick right yeah we
can now you know as you play this game
obviously your car the way you customize
the car will be part of that real world
that you're seeing all right so yes we
are definitely now blending real and
game two-degree there where people can't
tell the difference so let's talk a
little bit so 2014 we didn't have a need
for speed which had been the first time
I think it over a decade we had a year
without any speed behind many years yeah
so what has that extra year given you so
you know it really happened you know
when we started goes games four years
ago and we started making a need for
speed and we made rivals and we ship
that in 2013 I think we actually spoke
about that back in the day then we we
really stepped back and wanted to do the
game we really wanted to make and to do
that we need to understand one even need
to speak stand for so you know building
up and building up the brand from you
know kind of game pillars we spoke to
our fans you know what what is the need
to speak you want to be seeing
and fundamentally that is the game we're
building now we're building the game
that we know they want and you know that
we're suppose we've seen has been as I
said spectacular the announcement
trailer we've put out like a month ago
you know five and a half million views
this is unbelievable so we you know I
for me it kind of feels like we've woken
up this dormant population of people who
love me for speed and we're you know and
now obviously here III we deliver upon
it because people can play it yes so
let's talk a little bit about what the
game involves so there's kind of five
ways of looking at being a racer really
so you know with this game we're going
back to car culture right car culture at
large getting the details right in the
most iconic cars in that world and yes
you look at five ways to play which
fundamentally builds up five very
interesting ways to be a part of this
culture and so if you know you can you
can go you know speed style crew build
or outlaw which is also in a very neat
way summarizes that kind of cool you
know arcade arcade edgy receipts Need
for Speed experience right go insanely
fast sliding through the corner sideways
and a customized ride together with your
friends but one of the copis after you
so yeah you know it's that those five
days of play five ways of playing the
game it's kind of how you you you've
been pulled through the game yeah so you
mentioned I remember reading when the
game was first announced that there's
gonna be a kind of immersive storyline
how is that how is that how can you do
that in a kind of a game it's about
racing cars I take it are we gonna be
able to get out of the car you know like
that kind of stuff or is it a way of
there's a sniper someone will shoot me
if I go into that so we're not gonna do
that but I can say as much as there are
plenty of ways to where you can you can
tell a story in racing game and I go as
far as saying you're not gonna be it's
not gonna be a story where you you drift
around a corner to save the world
imagine if that was a game that I'd play
that maybe III wouldn't so I mean so
nobody's going
well how do you kind of feel you said it
twice the size of rivals yeah how do you
kind of keep that world engaging filled
of content filled with amazing things
for races to discover so you know
basically looking at this world as a you
know we talk about distraction based
gameplay like you've seen in other open
world games you know you go out there
you think you're gonna be doing
something and all of a sudden you're
doing something else and if you think
about this all drive world that we have
or we have this seamless connection or
you know a seamless blend between
single-player co-op and multiplayer
really play with play up to seven
friends in whatever you do you can play
alone you can play with one friend to
three friends it really is it really is
that is part of the destruction based
gameplay but that you have it you add
the cops to that you add all the
different you know roads challenges
missions then all of a sudden you have a
very you know emergent world which is
going to kind of pull you in and not let
you go yeah so you spoke earlier about
car customization and from from the
looks of it this is going really in
depth you talk a little bit more about
that yeah one of the really first things
that our fans told us and you know you
had to be you know pretty
non-intelligent I think if you want to
reboot if you speed and not do it with
customization right but then you can do
customization in many ways and you know
we would be we've gone really kind of
full-on on it down to the the you know
the smallest little detail of cars you
know you know from a color perspective
from parts perspective one thing that's
really key for us though is that we keep
it you know authentic you know that we
have we have chosen the most iconic cars
the the parts that we put on that are
kind of authentic aftermarket parts to
the to the you know largest possible
degree so it's it's it's not only about
you know making a customization system
it's about making it the right way for
the audience that we want to reach are
you also trying to encourage players to
kind of form a bond as a sort of
relationship with their vehicle yeah I
think that's natural right you know
we're going to saw what kind of game
you're playing
you know if you have something that we
want you to develop whether it's a
soldier weapon whatever it is you you do
grow kind of bond to it right you know I
think me plenty of games have done it
outside racing by cars absolutely you
know if we can give you access to a car
that you you've always wanted to drive
you can you can now personalize it from
a you know how it sounds from how it
handles to what it looks like and follow
the kind of rule system that the hottest
trends in car culture yeah yeah you will
develop a bond to that car so Need for
Speed going for over 20 years it has
real legacy it has you know it's been
handed over to a number of different
Studios like slightly mad criterion of
course and now it's found its home at
Ghost
what's that kind of been like was there
a pressure or was it do you see more of
an opportunity to really stamp your name
on this amazing series why I think
taking money for speed is a big honor
and and if you look at equal speed you
know honestly it's one of the most still
probably one of the most globally known
brands in gaming you know if you look at
you know different continents China you
know Nepos means massive so yeah of
course they say there's this pressure
there to do something with it but I
think that with ghosts we've obviously
built something up from from the ground
up and and you know we have we have
Intel enough people in our studio to
understand that we'll get to will get to
what our people you know that our fans
want if we speak to our fans and that's
what we're doing and you do have a real
strong bond with them because there's
there's a dedicated core community just
for Need for Speed what's it been like
with that interaction yeah so we we
obviously have this almost almost like a
car culture media web house which was
called speed hunters speed hunters as
you can hear from the word speed hunting
they they are out there on the globe and
they have people all over the world
basically and they we call them that
they are they you know our finger on the
pulse when it comes to car culture and
they that they are they totally making
us a better authoring because they give
us the expertise you know these are the
iconic cars these they're
parts that you have should put on your
car these are the people you should talk
to this is the environment you should go
into so we try you know really with them
we can be more legit in their offering
Marcus thank you so much for joining me
that's all we have time for make sure
you stay tuned here to the GameSpot
stage for more continuing coverage of e3
2015 I keep saying it it's been an
amazing year so make sure you don't go
anywhere we have so much more awesome
stuff coming right up